I do a pretty good spongebob boys you do
it now we're gonna talk about some mins
you might have missed this week on
YouTube throw it up Jillian let's get
this over with one two three
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's from our good friends over at
Nickelodeon that's obviously Sponge Bob
singin sweet victory with spongebob a
big part of childhood was my screen name
was love Patrick star 5 just remembering
now after like after college we I
graduated college and then I was like
hanging out with all these like cool
kids like they like owned a house
together and I was like trying to be
like I should live here too on that at
the New Year's party I kept doing the
spongebob voice cuz I was really drunk
and I was like I'm really good at this
guys like this is cool and looking bad
like waking up I was like eh like why
did I - yeah it's not a good move Jordan
saying I should live here - reminds me
of the story you told last night when
you said you realized in high school for
the pro that people hung out outside of
school genuinely yeah it was like junior
year I was like wait what do you these
because they're like talking about like
Kenya school just went home and played
Starcraft like I politely would sit and
be like can't wait to see my friends at
school still think you're good at that
spongebob impression now I know he's not
[Applause]
you were doing that all night at a party
myself yeah it's no way you get invited
out after school with that Jillian let's
play that next video so this is from the
dudes at dude perfect they're going for
the world record obviously of surfing on
exercise balls they got to get all the
way to the end Thank You Jillian so good
and dude perfect if you want to watch
see if they get it spoiler alert they do
because that doesn't look that hard
world records are like they're the first
people who fought to put a hundred of
those medicines in a row I mean no shade
dude perfect but like I haven't guessed
world record for eating the most amount
of candy corn before 10 a.m.
[Laughter]
yeah like are there standards I have no
idea well that was an old record that he
broke like what is that guy's job you
know what does he do that's to do a
group of dudes you like were in half you
could tell they were not that cool
things are really good at everything you
know I like those guys I go back to high
school and I saw them like how they're
cool with a lot of like trickshot stuff
so it's like throwing a football into a
basketball hoop like from the top of the
stadium and I think the trick is that
they just try it a hundred times and
then I show you the clip where they get
it but they also are very like athletic
in town I want to live with you guys if
you're watching I do a pretty good
spongebob boys you do it now
[Laughter]
[Music]
just judging those guys on their video
my criminal name is Carson you know we
have to say McCarley Carson cocaine it's
very Irish
oh yes McCauley Carson McDonough Carson
Kerrigan and I thought like you know I
should probably spruce up my name Colin
he was talking about this new website
venture that he started called Bernier's
calm and kind of is a promotional stunt
for that you can go vote up until
December 25th and this is true choose
his middle name and he's legally gonna
change it from Carson to either macaulay
culkin shark we akhirin which is his
brother's name the McRib is back or
publicity stunt
right now Macaulay Culkin is way out in
the lead with 40 I don't have a middle
name yeah whoever pays the most amount
of money gets to change your middle name
to whatever yeah I will take whatever I
know your middle name to be what relax
oh yeah relax what do you guys think
Hannah's middle name juice oh what if it
were my name that'd be cute Hannah
Jordan Mendoza Mendoza do it how hard is
it to change legally change your
building give the girl like City Hall
and pay 50 bucks I am making that up
those are some videos a couple days ago
we did a pun battle between Chris and
Natasha don't go swimming in the ocean
if you have terrible credit or you'll be
attacked by a loan shark
[Music]
so make sure to bring sand dollars Wow
dress your turn to response all right
almost drill at the beach I sweat like a
quart of water court to water quarter we
asked you guys to vote on your own best
puns what was your favorite Jordan
Spencer T says cryptocurrency goes up
and down because of speculative bubbles
okay that's one that's really good breck
sitters euro Nate in the English Channel
[Music]
the Chinese have a yen for currency okay
current C okay have you seen the
divorced fish that currency exchange is
obvious okay wait I have a good that I
actually reading that one I don't get
that either the chicken of the sea
Esquire is legal tender okay I should
have more carefully read and then she
this one I like she sells shekels by the
seashore all right thanks so those were
the videos you might have missed this
week now Hannah's gonna tell you about
all the news stories you might have
missed and she's gonna make some jokes
about them here's cheers to you
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah Dickinson and this is
cheers to you where I'm kicking out my
first round of the weekend bye cheers
into all the people and stories that
encouraged me to drink Cheers - Gwyneth
Paltrow for claiming you invented yoga
you didn't but to be fair everything you
say does put people in an uncomfortable
position so I'm with you girl cheers you
tumblr for banning adult content oh no
where am I gonna get porn if you are
upset that tumblr is banning adult
content you need to stop watching porn
at your public library
cheers to you ariana grande for saying
you can't date normally weird Saints
apparently ariana grande said she can't
like meet someone at a bar good to know
I'm not alone even though I'm literally
always alone cheers to you Harvard
professor for claiming you should only
eat six fries a day six fries a day how
about just saying don't eat fries that's
like saying only have six drinks a day
what's the point
cheers to you Burger King for offering a
deal of buying a whopper and getting a
dog treat for free in other words two
whoppers I love dog food dog treats are
like pretty good haven't you ever been
in line at Petco like I'll try it
I don't even have a dog cheers to you ed
Sheeran for being wildly underdressed
singing next to Beyonce
it's almost like she's better than you
to be fair ed Sheeran would look under a
dress next to a plate of romaine cheers
you twelve million pounds of beef that
was recalled last week wow that sounds
like my labia surgery
one of the videos that we in talked
about that's trending is the Captain
Marvel trailers out the second one right
yes the second trailer it's good she's
an old lady in it
yeah oh that's cool what a bus why would
a Captain Marvel be riding a bus that
almost be like if Comedy Central was
riding a bus called Captain Marvel yep
that logic works out and that just was
equally as good every damn day you can
also check us out on Twitter extra damn
day where we talking about what's
trending on Twitter you'll even see
Chris make some more jokes
[Laughter]
[Music]